Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
What a wonderful day to talk about fluid simulations!
This technique is an extension to Smoothed
Particle Hydrodynamics, or SPH in short, which
is a widely used particle-based simulation
technique where the visual quality scales
with the number of simulated particles.
The more particles we use in the simulation,
the more eye candy we can expect.
And the goal here is to create an extension
of these SPH-based simulations to include
deformable bodies and granular materials to
the computations.
This way, it is possible to create a scene
where we have instant coffee and soft candy
dissolving in water.
Which not only looks beautiful, but sounds
like a great way to get your day started.
Normally, we have to solve a separate set
of equations for each of the phases or material
types present, but because this proposed method
is able to put them in one unified equation,
it scales well with the number of materials
within the simulation.
This is not only convenient from a theoretical
standpoint, but it also maps well to parallel
architectures and the results shown in the
video were run on a relatively high-end consumer
NVIDIA card.
This is remarkable, as it should not be taken
for granted that a new fluid simulation technique
runs well on the GPU.
The results indeed indicate that the number
of phases only have a mild effect on the execution
time of the algorithm.
A nice and general framework for fluid-solid
interactions, dissolution, elastoplastic solids,
and deformable bodies.
What a fantastic value proposition.
I could watch and play with these all day.
I'll try my best to resist, but in case the
next episode is coming late, you know where
I am.
The quality of the paper is absolutely top
tier and if you like physics, you're going
to have lots of fun reading it.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!